hi I'm with Jen who's a lead designer
with Google Apps accessibility and Jen
has over 15 years of design experience
and today Jen I'm really curious to get
your insight our students have learned
about user interaction and information
design what else is important when it
comes to designing a good product I
think one of the key things that a lot
of people overlook initially but is
extremely important is accessibility and
what's accessibility accessibility is
about trying to make products that are
accessible and usable by all people
regardless if they have a disability or
not it's closely related to Universal
Design which is all about the process of
making products usable by people with
all ranges of abilities as well as they
can use them in all ranges of situations
so just thinking about if you can
envision a user using your product with
one hand maybe it wasn't designed
intentionally for that but can they use
it with one hand and this would benefit
users that might have certain motor
impairments but it would also benefit
users that maybe are have a hand busy
holding a baby or a large bag of
groceries that's kind of the idea behind
accessibility design okay and you
mentioned some of the impairments that
someone might have what other sorts of
impairments might people bring to a
product or might prevent them from
successfully using a product in the
first place there's a number of common
impairments that we consider and they
they range from having visual
impairments being color blind having
hearing impairments cognitive
impairments and motor impairments and
the thing to note with all of these is
that there's a wide range of severity
within each of these impairments so you
could have just slight vision loss to
being totally blind and the other thing
is that a lot of people tend to have
multiple impairments at one time so it's
it definitely makes things interesting
to design for but it's it's certainly
reality that we need to consider and one
of the things that I always love to to
talk to people about and remind them
when you start to think about designing
for people with disabilities a lot of
people tend to
kind of treat them as like they're in a
separate group and it's a group of
people that you could consider or could
not consider but in reality we're all
going to have some sort of impairment
most likely and within our lifetime one
of the important things that I feel that
people need to keep in mind is that the
when you're thinking about people with
disabilities a lot of designers and
different people tend to think of them
as a totally separate group that may or
may not our can or cannot be considered
in the process but in actuality all of
us are going to have a disability at
some point in our lives and these things
can be temporary like a broken arm they
can be situational like if you're riding
a bike and maybe can't see your fault
your small phone screen and they can be
just natural progression of Aging so
these it's really important to consider
these things because if you're not in a
sense you're not considering how to
design these products for yourself at
some point yeah so what what other
considerations I guess are why would it
be important for entrepreneurs to think
about accessibility first well one huge
thing is that there is a large
population of people with with
disabilities so there's a lot of great
research out there about the
demographics of people and we compiled
some research and noted that there are
more people with color blindness than
there are native English speakers in the
world so this is a huge population and
just thinking as an entrepreneur that
that's a huge pool of people and an
audience that you can tap into from a
financial profit standpoint obviously
another motivator if you're looking to
get involved in education or government
there's some legal considerations there
and some legal standards that you need
to meet but I think most importantly
what we have found is that when you
consider accessibility upfront it often
leads to a much better product for
everybody yeah and what's one example of
a product like that you've seen well one
really simple example and
straightforward thing that everyone can
start doing if you're designing a
digital product is think about can a
user complete all the necessary tasks on
your product using just a keyboard so
not only is this kind of
official to somebody that uses a screen
reader or doesn't have the dexterity to
use a mouse but it's also really
powerful or useful for the power users
that you might have that like to use
keyboards because they feel it's more
efficient